Well, it's just like they say in Us Weekly, people in the 18th century, they're just like us. At least they are when they're not in situations like the one I'm about to describe to you. It's 1761, Austria, cue the Mozart music, which, by an act of Congress in 1974, is required in any Public Radio story like this. Mozart, please.
就像《美国周刊》里说的那样，18世纪的人和我们没什么两样。至少在他们不处于我即将描述的那种处境时是这样。那是1761年的奥地利，请配上莫扎特的音乐，根据1974年的一项国会法案，这类公共广播报道都必须配上这种音乐。莫扎特，请开始。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Ava Litzelfelnerin gets married. She's 25, moves from her parents' farm to her husband's farm 16 miles away, which back then seemed really, really far away.
艾娃·利策尔费尔内林（Ava Litzelfelnerin）结婚了。她25岁，从父母的农场搬到了16英里外丈夫的农场，在那时看来，这真的很远很远。
She feels like she's in a foreign country when she's moved these 16 miles to the new village. And she says things like, oh, I don't know what the local customs are here.
当她搬到这16英里外的新村庄时，她感觉自己仿佛到了国外。她说，噢，我不知道这里当地的风俗是什么。
That's Kathy Stuart, a professor of history at the University of California Davis. She says that from hundreds of pages of archived criminal testimony, we know that this was an arranged marriage, that Ava met her husband days before the wedding, and that Ava's new mother-in-law dominated the household, wouldn't even let Ava give gifts to the neighbors when she moved in. The mother-in-law gave the field hands smaller portions of food than Ava thought was right, and she wouldn't let Ava change it or take charge. Ava tells people how unhappy she is in this new life far from the life she'd known.
那是加州大学戴维斯分校的历史学教授凯西·斯图尔特（Kathy Stuart）。她说，从数百页的档案刑事证词中，我们知道这是一桩包办婚姻，艾娃在婚礼前几天才见到她的丈夫，而且艾娃的新婆婆控制着整个家，甚至不让她在搬进来时给邻居送礼物。婆婆给长工的食物分量比艾娃认为的要少，也不让她去改变或做主。艾娃告诉人们，她在这种远离她所知生活的新生活中是多么不快乐。
She is constantly articulating to her husband, her brother, her mother that she wants to leave this world, and she can find no happiness in this world. And the only response she gets is go home and pray and work.
她不断地向丈夫、兄弟、母亲表达她想离开这个世界的想法，在这个世界上她找不到任何快乐。而她得到的唯一回应就是回家祈祷和工作。
So she decides to end her life, but there's a problem. At the time, suicide was considered a worse sin than murder. Kathy Stuart says the logic was, if you committed a murder, you could confess your sin, and if you were truly repentant, you could get yourself into Heaven. Obviously, if you kill yourself, you don't get that chance, and you are doomed to eternal damnation. And Ava did not want to go to Hell, but she thought of a loophole-- a morbid, little loophole.
于是她决定结束自己的生命，但有个问题。当时，自杀被认为比谋杀更严重的罪行。凯西·斯图尔特说，当时的逻辑是，如果你犯了谋杀罪，你可以忏悔你的罪孽，如果你真心悔过，你就能进入天堂。显然，如果你自杀了，你就没有那个机会了，而且你注定会受到永恒的诅咒。艾娃不想下地狱，但她想到了一个漏洞——一个病态的小漏洞。
She thought, OK, wait a minute. What if I commit suicide in a way that is really slow and secret. And I can get myself to a priest on time to confess before I die, and then nobody need know that I committed suicide, and I'll get to Heaven anyway. So what she does is, she goes to a nearby town, and she goes from store to store trying to buy arsenic.
她想，好吧，等一下。如果我用一种非常缓慢且隐秘的方式自杀呢？我可以在死前及时找到牧师忏悔，这样就没人知道我自杀了，我照样能上天堂。于是，她去了附近的一个城镇，挨家挨户地试图购买砷（砒霜）。
She testifies later this turns out to be really, really hard. Arsenic is a controlled substance. Nobody wants to sell it to her. Finally, she makes up a story about working for a farmer who has a rodent problem, which works.
她后来作证说，这实际上非常非常困难。砷是一种受管制物质。没人愿意卖给她。最后，她编造了一个谎言，说她是在为一个有鼠患的农场主工作，这才成功买到。
And then she goes home and she takes the arsenic. But she takes apparently just a little bit of arsenic, the way she describes it, as much as you could get on the point of a butter knife.
然后她回到家服下了砷。但据她描述，她显然只服用了极少量的砷，大概就是黄油刀尖上能挑起的分量。
It's delicate, right? She wants to take enough arsenic that it'll kill her, but not so much that it'll kill her quickly. She needs time to get to a priest first to confess the sin.
很微妙，对吧？她想服用足够的砷让自己死去，但又不能太多，以免死得太快。她需要时间先去找牧师忏悔罪过。
So she takes this little bit of arsenic. But apparently it was enough to make her violently ill, and for a week, every time she ate, she vomited. But it wasn't enough to make her think that she was now going to die.
于是她服用了这一点点砷。但这显然足以让她剧烈呕吐，接连一周，她吃什么吐什么。但这些分量还不足以让她觉得自己快要死了。
So she never goes to the priest. Figuring out the proper dosage, she testifies later, is just a vexing problem that she doesn't know how to solve. And she gives up that plan, which brings her to a much more disturbing plan. She decides to do something that, to us, to our modern sensibility, is so much worse than killing yourself. From our point of view, she decides to do one of the worst things a person could possibly do.
所以她从未去找过牧师。她后来作证说，找出合适的剂量是一个令人头疼的问题，她不知道该怎么解决。于是她放弃了这个计划，这让她转向了一个更令人不安的计划。她决定做一件在我们现代人看来，比自杀还要糟糕得多的事情。从我们的角度来看，她决定做一件一个人可能做出的最糟糕的事情。
She decides, I'm going to murder a child.
她决定，我要杀一个孩子。
That's right. She's going to murder a child to help herself get into Heaven. And incredibly, Kathy Stuart says this was a common strategy around that time for people who wanted to kill themselves. She came across a case like this and then went looking for others like it. And now she has found around 300, most of them women.
没错。她要杀一个孩子来帮助自己进入天堂。令人难以置信的是，凯西·斯图尔特说，这在那段时间里是人们想要自杀时的一种常见策略。她偶然发现了一个这样的案例，然后去寻找其他类似的情况。现在她已经发现了大约300个案例，其中大多数是女性。
These people don't want to go to Hell. So the option that they choose is to commit a capital crime. Immediately upon committing the crime, they run to the court. They confess what they have done, and they essentially demand their own execution.
这些人不想下地狱。所以他们选择的方案就是犯下一项重罪。在犯罪后立即跑去法院。他们供认自己所做的事，并本质上要求对自己执行死刑。
So they demand execution knowing that before they go to the gallows, they will have a chance to confess. And if they're truly repentant, they'll go to Heaven. And why kill a child?
所以他们要求执行死刑，因为他们知道在走向绞刑架之前，他们会有机会忏悔。如果他们真心悔过，他们就能上天堂。那为什么要杀孩子呢？
They kill a child because the child is seen as being in a state of innocence. So you might possibly be doing the child a favor, because the child will also go to Heaven. You will go to Heaven. It's kind of a win-win situation. There's a happy ending for all.
他们杀孩子是因为孩子被视为处于无辜状态。所以你可能是在帮那个孩子一个忙，因为孩子也会上天堂。你也会上天堂。这算是一种双赢的局面。皆大欢喜。
Yes, the classic happy ending. An innocent child gets an untimely death. Ava has to try this twice before she succeeds. The first time, she pushes a boy, who is described as being tall as a chair, into a river. But then someone spots them, and it seems like that person might rescue the boy. And so she decides, well, she should just rescue the boy herself. And then the boy ends up running away, and it doesn't work out.
是的，经典的圆满结局。一个无辜的孩子遭遇了不幸的死亡。艾娃尝试了两次才成功。第一次，她把一个被描述为只有椅子那么高的男孩推进了河里。但随后有人发现了他们，看起来那个人可能会救起那个男孩。于是她决定，好吧，她应该自己去救那个男孩。然后那个男孩跑掉了，计划没成。
The second time, she wanders to a nearby village called Traun, which has a little waterfall. She walks by a house, notices some baby clothes on a clothesline. Ava steals the baby, who is this couple's only child. The woman's 37. The man is 58. Ava throws the baby into the river and then turns herself in. Later, interestingly, when she's interrogated, she never actually seems too regretful about what she has done to this other family.
第二次，她溜达到了附近一个叫特劳恩（Traun）的村庄，那里有一个小瀑布。她经过一所房子，注意到晾衣绳上有一些婴儿衣服。艾娃偷走了那个婴儿，那是那对夫妇唯一的孩子。那名女子37岁，男子58岁。艾娃把婴儿扔进了河里，然后自首了。有趣的是，后来她在接受审讯时，似乎对自己对那家人所做的事从没感到过太多的悔意。
Just before her ultimate condemnation, in the last interrogation the interrogator asks her, is there anything else you want to say? Is there any regret you want to express? And again, she expresses regret for the distress and dishonor that she has caused her husband and her family. But she never even mentions the child or the child's parents. And I thought that was quite striking.
就在她最终被判刑前，最后一次审讯中，审讯官问她：还有什么要说的吗？有什么悔恨想表达吗？她再次表达了对自己给丈夫和家庭带来的痛苦和耻辱感到悔恨。但她从未提起那个孩子或孩子的父母。我认为这一点非常令人震惊。
Well, she's not sorry.
好吧，她并不觉得抱歉。
No, she's not sorry, one might say.
不，她并不觉得抱歉，有人可能会这么说。
So she's not going to Heaven, right? She's not sorry for the murder. This whole plan of hers is not going to work.
所以她上不了天堂，对吧？她对谋杀没有悔意。她这整个计划是行不通的。
Well, the pastor will say to the person being executed, do you think God can be fooled in this manner? You know that by doing this, you actually have committed suicide and so forth. And so the pastors really do address that theological problem, that this is a loophole. You're trying to cheat God. But because they have enough time, the condemned criminal can say, oh, yes, I was trying to cheat God. I was trying to commit suicide, and I repent. So confession takes care of it all.
嗯，牧师会对将被处决的人说，你以为上帝能被这样愚弄吗？你知道通过这样做，你实际上已经自杀了等等。所以牧师们确实指出了那个神学问题，即这是一个漏洞。你是在试图欺骗上帝。但因为他们有足够的时间，被判死刑的罪犯可以回答：噢，是的，我是在试图欺骗上帝。我是想自杀，我忏悔。所以忏悔就能解决这一切。
It doesn't seem fair.
这看起来不公平。
No, it really doesn't.
不，确实不公平。
Kathy Stuart says these kinds of suicides, suicides by proxy, she calls them, started in the mid 1600s. By 1700, officials in European cities were starting to notice this new trend of people murdering children so that they would get executed. And the officials tried to adjust the laws to stop it. In 1702, officials in Nuremberg made the execution more painful and shameful for these cases. It didn't work.
凯西·斯图尔特说，这些自杀方式，她称之为代理自杀，始于17世纪中期。到了1700年，欧洲城市的官员开始注意到这种谋杀儿童以求被处决的新趋势。官员们试图调整法律来阻止它。1702年，纽伦堡的官员让这些案件的行刑变得更加痛苦和耻辱。但这没用。
In 1767, they finally do the only logical thing to close this loophole. People are killing children because they want to get the death penalty. OK, they remove the death penalty for this kind of case. That didn't work either.
1767年，他们终于做了唯一合理的举措来堵住这个漏洞。人们杀孩子是因为他们想被判死刑。好吧，他们取消了这类案件的死刑。但这也没用。
Cases keep happening until the early decades of the 19th century. So it really seems like people didn't get the memo. It probably dissuaded some people, but people keep doing it.
此类案件一直持续到19世纪初。所以看起来人们真的没有收到消息。这可能劝阻了一些人，但人们还是不停地这样做。
Today on our show, we have a story about this cat-and-mouse game where rules are set, and someone tries to bend around the rules to get what they want.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一个关于猫捉老鼠游戏的故事，其中规则被设定好了，而有人试图绕过规则去得到他们想要的东西。
As any parent knows, starting pretty much as soon as a child is able to understand the fact that rules exist-- you know, don't touch the stove; don't put that in your nose-- they start to test the boundaries of the rule, to poke at it, to look for loopholes.
正如任何家长所知，孩子从刚开始能理解规则存在的那一刻起——你知道，别碰炉子；别把那个塞进鼻子里——他们就开始测试规则的边界，试探它，寻找漏洞。
Today we have the story of somebody who takes pleasure in doing just that. He takes pleasure in the ingenuity of it, of finding a loophole that nobody else has noticed, and exploiting it as long as he can until the authorities notice him.
今天我们要讲的故事是关于一个以这样做为乐的人。他从这种独创性中获得快感，发现了一个没人注意到的漏洞，并尽可能久地利用它，直到当局注意到他。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。请留步。
Act One, Death Takes a Policy.
第一幕，死亡带来的政策。
Joseph Caramadre is a wealthy philanthropist and a devout Catholic. In his huge house in the Providence suburbs, he has a near-life-size statue of Saint Joseph displayed in its own alcove in the living room. He's given millions of dollars to charities, especially the Catholic Church.
约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷（Joseph Caramadre）是一位富有的慈善家和虔诚的天主教徒。在他位于普罗维登斯郊区的巨大房子里，客厅的一个壁龛里陈列着一尊真人大小的圣约瑟夫雕像。他捐赠了数百万美元给慈善机构，特别是天主教会。
In 2009, the local United Way gave him one of its highest individual honors-- the Tocqueville Society Philanthropy Award-- for his work on behalf of more than 40 different charities. Joseph Caramadre is also, depending on who you talk to, either a criminal mastermind, or just a regular, law-abiding guy, who managed to take advantage of loopholes to turn the tables on some of the largest corporations in the country and beat them at their own game.
2009年，当地的联合之路（United Way）授予他最高个人荣誉之一——托克维尔社会慈善奖——以表彰他为40多个不同慈善机构所做的工作。约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷也是，取决于你问谁，他要么是个犯罪策划大师，要么只是一个守法的普通人，他成功地利用漏洞，在全国一些大公司身上扭转了局势，在他们自己的游戏中击败了他们。
Jake Bernstein from ProPublica teams up with Alex Blumberg from our own Planet Money team to tell the story.
ProPublica的杰克·伯恩斯坦（Jake Bernstein）与我们《金钱星球》团队的亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）联手讲述了这个故事。
Before the criminal indictment, before the lawsuits, before the exposes on the local news, Joseph Caramadre had a prosperous business doing estate planning. He helped rich people prepare for their deaths, everything from taxes to life insurance.
在刑事起诉之前，在诉讼之前，在当地新闻曝光之前，约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷有一份蒸蒸日上的遗产规划业务。他帮助富人准备身后事，从税收到人寿保险应有尽有。
To give you a sense of what kind of guy he is, what makes him so good at this job, consider this story. He was at a local office superstore, and they were selling calendars with coupons on each page. He saw one of these coupon to that said $25 off any piece of office furniture. He read the fine print and realized the lawyers who wrote the language in that coupon had forgotten a key clause.
为了让你了解他是什么样的人，是什么让他如此擅长这项工作，考虑一下这个故事。他在当地一家办公用品超市，他们卖的日历每一页都有优惠券。他看到其中一张优惠券写着办公家具减免25美元。他读了细则，意识到写下那段文字的律师忘记了一个关键条款。
I noticed that mistake there. It was normal for me to notice it. I'm kind of hard wired for this.
我注意到了那个错误。注意到它对我来说很正常。我的大脑构造就是为了这些而生的。
Wait. What was the mistake?
等等。是什么错误？
The mistake was that they meant $25 off of any piece of furniture over $200. They forgot the over $200 part. So all the coupons were issued $25 off of any piece of furniture.
错误是他们本意是任何超过200美元的家具减免25美元。他们漏掉了超过200美元那部分。所以所有的优惠券都变成了任何家具减免25美元。
And there was lots of furniture that was less than $25?
而且有很多不到25美元的家具？
It was even worse than that. There was stuff $40 on sale for $25.
更糟的是。有些打折商品只要25美元。
Caramadre bought all the calendars he could. He bought so many of them, he says, they gave him a discount. And when that month for that $25 off coupon rolled around, he showed up at the store, and bought every piece of furniture under $25 he could find.
卡拉马德雷买了他能买到的所有日历。他说他买得太多，他们甚至给了他折扣。当那个25美元优惠券的月份到来时，他出现在商店里，买下了他能找到的所有25美元以下的家具。
And they rang it up. All right, it's $1200. And I just pull out a stack of coupons and say, all right, we're even. And the face on the managers-- the expression on the poor manager's face was such that the poor guy said I'm going to lose my job. I said it's not your fault that Legal doesn't know what the hell they're doing.
他们算完账说，总共1200美元。我就拿出一叠优惠券说，好吧，我们两清了。那位经理脸上的表情……那个可怜的家伙说我会被解雇的。我说，法律部门的人不知道自己在干什么，这又不是你的错。
Who does this? Think of the effort involved. He had to read through 12 months of the fine print, buy all those calendars, remember the scheme, and come back several months later to claim his prize. And for what? $1,200 of cheap office furniture that he didn't even need. He actually had to borrow a truck from a friend to take it all home, where he says he stored some of it in his garage and gave some to friends, family, and charity.
谁会这么做？想想这背后付出的努力。他必须读完12个月的细则，买下所有那些日历，记住这个计划，然后在几个月后回来兑现他的奖品。为了什么？1200美元他甚至根本不需要的便宜办公家具。他实际上不得不从朋友那里借了一辆卡车把它们全部运回家，他说他把其中一些存在车库里，剩下的送给了朋友、家人和慈善机构。
Joseph Caramadre has a compulsion for loopholes, for seeing the angle in a deal and exploiting it. In fact, when he discovers schemes like this, he calls them his creations. He actually numbers them. There have been 19 of them in his lifetime, he says. The office furniture one was number four. And it is number 18 we're talking about today, the one that first landed him in trouble.
约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷对漏洞有一种强迫症，喜欢在交易中寻找角度并加以利用。事实上，当他发现这样的计划时，他称它们为他的作品。他甚至给它们编了号。他说，他一生中有19个这样的作品。那个办公家具案是第四个。今天我们要谈的是第18个，也是让他第一次陷入麻烦的那个。
The seeds of number 18 came in the mid 1990s, in a place most of us would probably consider more likely to put us to sleep than spark an idea.
第18个计划的萌芽出现在90年代中期，在一个我们大多数人可能认为更容易让人昏昏欲睡，而不是激发灵感的地方。
One of the insurance companies was giving a seminar to agents, which I am a life insurance agent, where they were espousing the benefits of their variable annuities.
其中一家保险公司正在为代理人举办研讨会，我本身就是一名人寿保险代理人，他们在宣传他们变额年金的好处。
So Jake.
所以杰克。
Alex.
亚历克斯。
This is the part of the story where we have to explain what a variable annuity is.
这是故事中我们需要解释什么是变额年金的部分。
Yeah, but don't worry. It's not that complex. The variable annuity was a product that was just becoming popular around the time Joe went to the seminar. And though they were sold by life insurance companies, they were very different from a traditional life insurance policy.
是的，但别担心。它没那么复杂。变额年金是乔去参加那个研讨会时刚开始流行的一种产品。虽然它们是由人寿保险公司销售的，但它们与传统的人寿保险单非常不同。
A life insurance policy, you pay a little bit of money each year and, if you die, your beneficiaries, your spouse, your kids, will get a big payout.
人寿保险单，你每年付一点钱，如果你死了，你的受益人，你的配偶，你的孩子，会得到一大笔赔付。
Variable annuities are more like an investment. You have, say, a million dollars, and you purchase an annuity, which is then invested in a variety of different funds that you select-- mutual funds, stocks, bonds. The insurance companies give you an array of choices, and you tell them which funds get the money.
变额年金更像是一种投资。你有，比如说，一百万美元，你购买了一份年金，然后将其投资于你选择的各种不同基金——共同基金、股票、债券。保险公司提供一系列选择，你告诉他们钱投到哪些基金里。
This is the variable part of the equation. Now, you might be wondering, why not just put the money in a mutual fund yourself? Why go through the insurance company at all? Well, one of the main reasons, the insurance company has offered something called a death benefit guarantee.
这是方程中的变额部分。现在，你可能想知道，为什么不自己把钱投进共同基金呢？为什么要通过保险公司？嗯，主要原因之一，保险公司提供了一种叫做死亡赔付保证的东西。
With the death benefit guarantee, say you invest a million dollars, but the market crashes, and so does your investment. If you should die before the investment recovers, your beneficiary gets the original million, even if the account is worth half of that. You get all the upside without the downside.
有了死亡赔付保证，假设你投资了一百万美元，但市场崩溃了，你的投资也缩水了。如果你在投资回升前去世，你的受益人会得到最初的一百万美元，即使账户价值只有那一半。你得到了所有的上行空间，却没有下行风险。
All upside, no downside. This is the Holy Grail for any investor. Most investment managers will tell you it's impossible. You can't get reward without risk. Yet here it was, sitting before Caramadre, the proverbial free lunch-- with one very big catch.
有上行空间，无下行风险。这对任何投资者来说都是圣杯。大多数投资经理会告诉你这是不可能的。没有风险就没有回报。然而它就摆在卡拉马德雷面前，那句谚语中的免费午餐——只有一个非常大的前提。
That's really not a free lunch. I have to die.
这真的不是免费午餐。我必须得死。
To most of us, that having to die part, that would be a deal breaker, a sign to walk away. But to Caramadre, he could tell there was a creation in here somewhere, he just needed to find the loophole.
对我们大多数人来说，那句必须死的部分，会是一个交易破坏者，一个走开的信号。但对卡拉马德雷来说，他能看出这里面有一个作品，他只需要找到那个漏洞。
All we need to do is replace the necessity of the investor having to die with someone else dying. So if we could transfer and get a substitute life, we've effectively accomplished the investor not needing to die.
我们所要做的就是把投资者必须死亡的必要性替换成其他人死亡。所以如果我们能转移并获得一个替代生命，我们就有效地达成了投资者无需死亡的目的。
Joe started reading through prospectuses, the 100-page documents filled with legalese that explain the rules of each annuity plan. Lots of companies offered these annuities, Transamerica-- ING, MetLife, Nationwide. And it turns out, the way these variable annuity contracts were written, there was a loophole.
乔开始阅读招股说明书，那是写满法律术语、解释每种年金计划规则的百页文档。很多公司提供这些年金，泛美（Transamerica）、荷兰国际集团（ING）、大都会人寿（MetLife）、全国保险（Nationwide）。结果证明，变额年金合同的写法里，有一个漏洞。
Every annuity has three participants. There's the investor. That's the person who's putting up the million dollars, say. There's the beneficiary, the person who gets the money if the death benefit is triggered. And then there's a third party called an annuitant, or what's known as a measuring life.
每份年金都有三个参与者。一个是投资者。那是出资一百万美元的人，比如说。一个是受益人，如果触发死亡赔付，那是拿钱的人。然后还有第三方叫被保险人，或者被称为计量寿命（measuring life）。
And this third category, that annuitant person, that's where the loophole was found. The way the insurance companies intended it to work, the way it worked most of the time, was that the investor and the annuitant were the same person.
而这第三类，那个被保险人，就是发现漏洞的地方。保险公司预期的运作方式，以及大多数时候的运作方式，是投资者和被保险人是同一个人。
For example, I, Jake Bernstein, put up a million dollars to purchase an annuity. And if I, Jake Bernstein, die, then the death benefit gets triggered. I'm the investor. I'm also the annuitant. The beneficiary would usually be a family member.
例如，我，杰克·伯恩斯坦，出资一百万美元购买了一份年金。如果我，杰克·伯恩斯坦，死了，那么死亡赔付就被触发。我是投资者。我同时也是被保险人。受益人通常是家庭成员。
But Caramadre discovered legally you could set it up a different way. There was no requirement in the contracts that the annuitant be the investor. In fact, there was no requirement that the annuitant have any relationship to the investor at all. So in theory, I, Alex Blumberg, could put up a million dollars, but I could find someone else, my ailing grandmother or a perfect stranger, to be the annuitant, to be the person whose demise triggers the death benefit.
但卡拉马德雷发现，在法律上你可以换一种方式设立。合同中没有要求被保险人必须是投资者。事实上，没有要求被保险人与投资者有任何关系。所以理论上，我，亚历克斯·布隆伯格，可以出资一百万美元，但我可以找其他人，我病重的祖母或一个完全的陌生人来作为被保险人，作为那个其离世会触发死亡赔付的人。
If you can get a short life expectancy, you will be able to have your cake and eat it. You'll be able to invest any way you want to in these mutual funds and know it's like going to the horses. When you leave the horse track, if you won, you keep the winnings. If you lose, they give you your money back.
如果你能找一个预期寿命较短的人，你就能鱼与熊掌兼得。你可以随心所欲地投资这些共同基金，这就像去赛马场一样。当你离开赛马场时，如果你赢了，你保留奖金。如果你输了，他们把钱退还给你。
Now, there are laws against using insurance to profit from the deaths of strangers. You don't want people taking out an insurance contract on the neighbor down the street and then killing them. But according to a Rhode Island federal court, an annuity is fundamentally different than life insurance. So those laws about insuring strangers, they don't apply.
现在，法律禁止利用保险从陌生人的死亡中获利。你不会希望人们给街对面的邻居买保险然后杀死他们。但根据罗德岛州联邦法院的说法，年金与人寿保险本质上不同。所以那些关于为陌生人投保的法律，并不适用。
Which meant Caramadre's creation was almost complete. But before he brought it to his clients, he needed to test it, so he decided to buy one himself. He started small, an annuity for just $10,000. He was the investor. His wife Paula was the beneficiary. All he needed was an annuitant who might not be around for long.
这意味着卡拉马德雷的作品几乎完成了。但在他向客户推广之前，他需要测试一下，所以他决定自己买一份。他从小额开始，一份10000美元的年金。他是投资者。他的妻子宝拉是受益人。他只需要一个可能活不长久的被保险人。
In this case, it was a friend of the family I knew that our family in church was praying for because they had cancer, and I was helping to straighten out the estate of the family. So I happened to know the person and just asked them, can I use them as a measuring life.
在这种情况下，是一位家庭朋友，我知道我们教会的家人都在为他祈祷，因为他患有癌症，我当时正在帮那个家庭处理遗产问题。所以我碰巧认识那个人，就问他们，我可以用你作为计量寿命吗？
Was that-- were you nervous to first have that conversation?
那是——你第一次进行那次对话时紧张吗？
Yeah, I would say I was a little bit nervous, because we're talking about someone dying, and no one wants to talk about death. I think a lot of my success in the life insurance industry has been because I always treat death as a part of life, and it's very easy for me to talk about it. I'm around death all the time. Estate planning is all about death planning.
是的，我会说我有点紧张，因为我们谈论的是某人死亡，没人想谈论死亡。我认为我在人寿保险业的成功很大程度上是因为我总是把死亡当作生活的一部分，对我来说谈论它很容易。我总是接触死亡。遗产规划就是关于死亡规划。
So, for me, it was-- basically, I guess I might have been the first one to ever ask anyone, can we use their name and their health status for the benefit of others. Yes, I was a little nervous, but then, on the other hand, if the person didn't want to do it, they didn't have to do it. This was an opportunity for me to test something. And if it worked, then I could bring it into more of a multiple use.
所以，对我来说，它——我想我可能是第一个问任何人能否用他们的名字和健康状况为他人谋利的人。是的，我有点紧张，但另一方面，如果那个人不想做，他们也不必做。这是我测试某件事的一个机会。如果它成功了，那么我就可以把它带入更多的用途。
And it was also an opportunity for the annuitant, who was very sick and maybe struggling financially, to get some money. Caramadre says he initially paid this family friend around $500 for his signature and permission to use his name, date of birth, and social security number on the annuity form.
这对那个被保险人来说也是一个机会，他病得很重，经济上可能也很拮据，可以得到一些钱。卡拉马德雷说他最初为那个家庭朋友的签名以及允许在他的年金表格上使用他的名字、出生日期和社会保障号码支付了大约500美元。
Now, a lot of people might find this gross, taking a person's most vulnerable, emotional moment and turning it into an opportunity for financial gain. But on the other hand, this isn't trying to upsell a grieving family on a super deluxe casket. Sure, Caramadre and his clients were going to benefit. But Caramadre was giving this man and his family money, not taking money from them.
现在，很多人可能会觉得这很恶心，利用一个人最脆弱、最情绪化的时刻，把它变成财务收益的机会。但另一方面，这并不是试图向一个悲痛的家庭兜售豪华棺材。当然，卡拉马德雷和他的客户会获利。但卡拉马德雷是给了这个人及其家人钱，而不是拿走他们的钱。
On the application, the insurance companies only asked one question that touched on what Caramadre was planning to do. That single question? What is the relationship between the investor and the annuitant.
在申请书上，保险公司只问了一个触及卡拉马德雷计划要做的事情的问题。那唯一的问题是：投资者和被保险人之间的关系是什么？
I put N-O-N-E, none. No relationship.
我填了N-O-N-E，无。没有任何关系。
But they don't ask how healthy is he? They don't say, is he in a hospital? Is he in a hospice? None of that stuff.
但他们不问他有多健康？他们不说，他是在医院吗？他在临终关怀中心吗？没有那种东西。
No, not at all.
不，完全没有。
Within a few months, Caramadre's first annuitant died. Caramadre paid his respects to this family and submitted the death claim. His account had lost money. The original $10,000 investment was down to about $9,000. But the insurance company paid him his original investment plus interest, no questions asked. And I emphasize, no questions.
几个月内，卡拉马德雷的第一个被保险人去世了。卡拉马德雷向那家人表达了哀悼并提交了死亡赔付申请。他的账户亏损了。最初的10000美元投资缩水到了大约9000美元。但保险公司支付给他最初的投资额加上利息，没有任何疑问。我强调，没有任何疑问。
Did they say anything to you when you put in the claim after only four months, or three months, or whatever it was?
当你仅仅四个月，或者三个月，或者不管多久之后提交申请时，他们有没有对你说什么？
No. And let me make it a little bit more interesting. Right after that, we submitted four applications to the same company with four different investor owners using the same measuring life.
没有。而且让我把事情说得更有趣一点。在那之后，我们向同一家公司提交了四份申请，由四位不同的投资者所有者，使用同一个计量寿命。
So they found one dying person and filled out four different applications with four different investors all using the same guy as the annuitant. When that person died?
所以他们找了一个垂死的人，填写了四份不同的申请，四位不同的投资者都使用同一个人作为被保险人。当那个人去世时？
I actually sent in one piece of paper saying this person died, pay these four owners. And they said nothing. So they had--
我实际上寄了一张纸说这个人死了，赔付这四位所有者。他们什么也没说。所以他们有——
And they paid it?
他们赔付了吗？
Yeah, they paid it and processed it.
是的，他们赔付并处理了。
The insurance companies paid and processed it because the insurance companies made a lot of money. Remember the way this usually works. You put in your million dollars, and the life insurance company can collect upwards of 4% of that money in fees every year, potentially for decades. The way the insurance company saw it, these annuities were money makers. They didn't need to ask that many questions.
保险公司赔付并处理了它，因为保险公司赚了很多钱。记住这通常是如何运作的。你投入一百万美元，人寿保险公司每年可以从中收取高达4%的费用，可能会持续几十年。在保险公司看来，这些年金是赚钱的工具。他们不需要问那么多问题。
For Caramadre, though, it meant creation number 18 was fully operational. He'd found the loophole that made the free lunch possible.
不过对卡拉马德雷来说，这意味着第18个作品已全面投入运营。他找到了让免费午餐成为可能的漏洞。
OK, so now I have a creation on hand that has been tested at least preliminarily with a little bit of money. It has been tested that the company doesn't seem to care or want to care about underwriting, health questions, relationship, or even losses or gains. So I now start going to clients that are near and dear to me and tell them look, I think I have something special here.
好吧，现在我手头上有一个作品，至少已经用少量资金进行了初步测试。已经测试出公司似乎不在乎或不想去理会核保、健康问题、关系，甚至亏损或收益。所以我现在开始去找我亲近的客户，告诉他们看，我觉得我这儿有个特别的东西。
My name's Carl Ferreira. I'm a general dentist in Fall River, Massachusetts.
我是卡尔·费雷拉（Carl Ferreira）。我是马萨诸塞州福尔河（Fall River）的一名全科牙医。
Carl Ferreira met Joe Caramadre through his accountant, who told him about this smart attorney in Cranston, Rhode Island, who had a great investment opportunity. Carl met with Joe, learned the details of creation number 18, and said sign me up.
卡尔·费雷拉通过他的会计师认识了乔·卡拉马德雷，会计师告诉他关于罗德岛州克兰斯顿（Cranston）有一位聪明的律师，有一个很棒的投资机会。卡尔见了乔，了解了第18个作品的细节，然后说算我一个。
For me, it was an ideal position to put some of my pension money in, where there would be growth and guaranteed principal protection, and I would protect both myself and my employees from the fluctuations of the market.
对我来说，把一些退休金投入其中是一个理想的位置，既有增长又有保证的本金保护，我还能保护自己和员工免受市场波动的影响。
Your pension money meaning the pension money that you're paying for your employees?
你的退休金是指你为你员工支付的退休金吗？
Correct. And I also put some personal money in it as well.
正确。我也投了一些个人资金在里面。
For Ferreira, there was one other attractive feature to Caramadre's creation.
对于费雷拉来说，卡拉马德雷的作品还有另一个吸引人的特点。
One of the things I was thinking, and I thought, well, isn't this something? How many times had we dealt with insurance companies and been denied claims, whether it's on your homeowner's, or your medical insurance, or your dental insurance, and they refer you to some policy in fine print. And you say to yourself, you need a lawyer to read this.
我当时想的一件事是，我就想，这不就是某种东西吗？我们和保险公司打过多少次交道，理赔被拒绝过？无论是你的房主保险、医疗保险还是牙科保险，他们都会引用细则中的某项政策。你对自己说，你需要一个律师来读这个。
And I said isn't this great? Finally, there's a lawyer that read this and is now going to hoist them on their own petard. So we have this Italian lawyer from the hill that went to Suffolk law school at night and beat these guys from Harvard and Yale and Princeton at their own game.
我说这不是很棒吗？终于有一个律师读懂了这些，现在要让他们自食其果。所以我们有了这个来自山上的意大利律师，他晚上去萨福克（Suffolk）法学院上课，然后在他们自己的游戏中击败了哈佛、耶鲁和普林斯顿的那些家伙。
Ferreira says he never had any qualms about benefiting from someone else's death.
费雷拉说他从未对利用他人的死亡获利感到愧疚。
That wasn't really an issue for me. And I was so not squeamish about it that I brought that forth to my father when he was elderly. And he couldn't get the pen fast enough to sign.
这对我来说真的不是个问题。我一点也不忌讳，我甚至把它告诉了我年迈的父亲。他签名的速度简直快得不得了。
Oh, so you actually said, hey, dad, this guy Joe Caramadre, he could give you a couple thousand dollars if you sign your signature?
哦，所以你实际上说，嘿，老爸，这个叫乔·卡拉马德雷的家伙，只要你签个名就能给你几千美元？
He just signed it without the money. It was just, hey, Pop, I got this opportunity here. Do you want to sign this? And as I said, he couldn't get the pen fast enough. If there was going to be something that was going to be an advantage to his children, he was going to do that, dead or alive, or alive or dead, we would say.
他连钱都没看就签了。就只是，嘿，老爸，我这有个机会。你想签这个吗？正如我所说，他签名的速度简直快得不得了。如果这对他孩子有好处，他就会去做，无论是死是活，或者活是死，我们会这么说。
Throughout the '90s and early 2000s, word of Caramadre's creation spread amongst his clients and his acquaintances. It was never a big part of his overall business, he says. He puts it less than 5% of what he made. But among a certain type of person, getting in on creation number 18 became something like a trophy investment, something to brag about.
在整个90年代和2000年代初，卡拉马德雷的作品在客户和熟人中传开了。他说，这从来不是他整体业务的很大一部分。他所做的不到他收入的5%。但在某种人当中，参与第18个作品成了某种奖杯式投资，是值得炫耀的东西。
If there's a couple of people who are captains of industry at a country club, they're always boasting that their investment adviser got them this, and their car is the best, and all this. Their doctor's the best. So it actually got to the point where, if I wanted to, I could have a waiting list of people to beg me to take a million dollars. People wanted a piece of this, if they could hear about it, and if I would allow them in the game, if you will.
如果乡村俱乐部里有几个行业领袖，他们总是吹嘘他们的投资顾问为他们搞到了这个，他们的车是最好的，还有所有这些。他们的医生是最好的。所以它甚至达到了如果我愿意，我可以有一份排队名单让人们求我接受他们的一百万美元。人们想要这其中的一部分，如果他们能听到这个消息，如果我允许他们加入游戏的话，如果你愿意这么说的话。
Caramadre made money on this scheme in a variety of ways. Sometimes, he simply collected a fee. The insurance companies had these annuities they were trying to sell, and they paid the people who helped sell them a small percentage. Caramadre would take a cut of that percentage. On a few occasions, he says, he split some of the profit with the client.
卡拉马德雷通过多种方式从这个计划中赚钱。有时，他只是收取费用。保险公司有这些他们试图销售的年金，他们向帮助销售的人支付一小部分佣金。卡拉马德雷会分取那部分佣金。他说，在少数情况下，他与客户分摊了部分利润。
He would say to one of these captains of industry, I have this great opportunity for you. Give me a cut of whatever your investment makes. And sometimes, he would invest his own money in an annuity. Caramadre's lawyers have told him not to say exactly how much he made off of this scheme, but it was likely in the millions of dollars. Regardless, as he did more and more of these deals, he needed more and more people who were close to death.
他会对他那些行业领袖之一说，我为你提供了一个很棒的机会。把你投资利润的一部分给我。有时，他会把自己的钱投入年金。卡拉马德雷的律师告诉他不要透露他从这个计划中究竟赚了多少钱，但很可能高达数百万美元。无论如何，随着他做的交易越来越多，他需要更多快要死亡的人。
I started asking doctors, nursing homes, hospices, organizations, funeral homes, social workers if they knew of anyone who is terminally ill and needed money. If they refer them to me, and they want to participate in this program, I could find their money.
我开始问医生、养老院、临终关怀中心、组织、殡仪馆、社会工作者，他们是否认识任何绝症患者并需要钱。如果他们把我介绍给他们，他们也想参加这个项目，我就能找到他们的钱。
Raise your hand, please. Do you swear the testimony you're about to give will be the truth, the whole truth, nothing but the truth, so help you God?
请举起你的右手。你发誓你即将给出的证词将是真实的，全部真实的，除了真实什么都没有，上帝保佑你？
I do.
我发誓。
Would you state your name, please?
请说出你的名字？
Charles Buckman.
查尔斯·巴克曼（Charles Buckman）。
Please spell your last name.
请拼写你的姓氏。
B-U-C-K-M-A-N.
B-U-C-K-M-A-N。
Charles Buckman was one of several dozen dying people who filled out paperwork for Caramadre's deals. Some of these were also used in a slightly different scheme, creation number 19, which involved bonds, but was a close cousin of the variable annuity program.
查尔斯·巴克曼是为卡拉马德雷的交易填写文件的几十个垂死者之一。其中一些人也被用于另一个稍微不同的计划，第19个作品，涉及债券，但与变额年金项目是近亲。
Most of the participants in these schemes have died by now. We found two annuitants who are still alive, but they declined to talk to us. But we do have video testimony of several of these annuitants taken before they died. In this video, Charles Buckman has an oxygen tube going into his nose. He suffers from a chronic lung condition. He's also hard of hearing. He says he first got involved with creation number 18 in 2008. It started with his wife.
这些计划的大多数参与者现在都已经去世了。我们找到了两位仍然健在的被保险人，但他们拒绝与我们交谈。但我们确实有几位被保险人在去世前拍摄的视频证词。在这些视频中，查尔斯·巴克曼鼻子上插着氧气管。他患有慢性肺病。他还有听力障碍。他说他是2008年第一次参与第18个作品的。这是从他妻子开始的。
It started, my wife, she had cancer, and she was critical with cancer. And we had a visiting nurse who came two or three days a week, and she mentioned to my wife, she showed us a flyer and wanted to know if we ever got our $2,000. My wife said, what are you talking about? We had no idea. So she gave us the flyer. She said please call this number. So I did.
开始时，我的妻子，她得了癌症，而且癌症很严重。我们有一位上门护士一周来两三次，她向我妻子提到了这件事，她给我们看了一张传单，想知道我们是否收到过我们的2000美元。我妻子说，你在说什么？我们根本不知道。所以她给了我们传单。她说请打这个号码。所以我就打了。
By 2008 when Buckman got involved, Caramadre had taken out an ad in a local Catholic newspaper which said-- Terminal illness? $2000. And then all in capital letters-- IN CASH, immediately available.
到了2008年巴克曼参与时，卡拉马德雷已经在当地一份天主教报纸上登了一则广告，上面写着——绝症？2000美元。然后全部用大写字母——现金，即刻可用。
And the way it worked, everyone who answered the ad and could prove they had a terminal illness got a check for $2,000, whether they participated in Caramadre's program or not. If they decided to sign the documents and serve as a measuring life, there was more money available, usually between $3,000 and $10,000.
其运作方式是，任何回答广告并能证明他们患有绝症的人都能得到一张2000美元的支票，无论他们是否参加了卡拉马德雷的项目。如果他们决定签署文件并担任计量寿命，会有更多的钱，通常在3000到10000美元之间。
Caramadre had a young employee right out of college named Raymour Radhakrishnan, who was signing up most of the annuitants, including Charles Buckman.
卡拉马德雷有一名大学刚毕业的年轻员工叫雷穆尔·拉达克里希南（Raymour Radhakrishnan），他负责招募大多数被保险人，包括查尔斯·巴克曼。
He stopped in, and he visited with us. Just a friendly visit, like an old friend, more or less.
他顺路来访了我们。就像老朋友一样友好的访问，差不多是这样。
OK. Did he talk about--
好的。他谈到——
And he said he had a check for us.
他说他有一张支票给我们。
OK.
好的。
And he asked, who do I make it out to? And he was in a rush. He had other places he had to go that day, if I can remember correctly.
他问，支票抬头写谁的名字？他很匆忙。如果我记得没错的话，那天他还有别的地方要去。
OK.
好的。
He said Mr. Buckman, I'd like to stay longer, but I have other appointments. He says, if you don't mind, I'll call you at a later date. And I'd like to set up another meeting with you and come back to visit with you and your wife.
他说巴克曼先生，我想多呆一会儿，但我还有其他预约。他说，如果你不介意，我会改天再打电话给你。我想再和你和你妻子安排一次会议，再回来拜访你们。
OK.
好的。
And I said fine. I said anybody that comes to my house and gives me $2,000 is welcome anytime.
我说没问题。我说任何来我家给我2000美元的人都随时欢迎。
A welcome visitor?
受欢迎的访客？
Yep.
是的。
Raymour came back a few days later with documents to sign. Mr. Buckman says Raymour read him the documents and explained that there's a group of people making an investment, and these people could make money if someone dies. He says he knew that he and his wife wouldn't get any of that money. Their only payouts were the checks they would collect for signing these documents.
雷穆尔几天后带着要签署的文件回来了。巴克曼先生说雷穆尔给他读了文件，并解释说有一群人正在进行一项投资，如果有人死亡，这些人就能赚钱。他说他知道他和妻子拿不到那笔钱。他们的唯一收入就是他们签署这些文件所收取的支票。
Buckman and his wife ended up signing papers on nine transactions. Caramadre says he paid the couple a total of $12,000. To Buckman, it was a great deal. He said so to Raymour.
巴克曼和他的妻子最终在九笔交易的文件上签了字。卡拉马德雷说他一共付给这对夫妇12000美元。对巴克曼来说，这非常划算。他就是这么告诉雷穆尔的。
What I told Raymour was, my wife-- I can't thank him enough. And he can tell you, I could not thank him enough, him and his boss, for supplying my wife with the best days of her life for the couple months before she passed away. And to this day, I'll be forever grateful.
我告诉雷穆尔的是，我的妻子——我怎么感谢他都不为过。他可以告诉你，我和他的老板，感谢你们在我妻子去世前的几个月里，为她提供了她生命中最美好的日子。直到今天，我永远都会心存感激。
Buckman said he couldn't care less how much Caramadre and others were getting.
巴克曼说他才不在乎卡拉马德雷和其他人拿了多少钱。
No matter what they had, I could care less how much they got. I know that my wife had the best time of her life because of what they did for her. And I'll never be thankful enough.
不管他们拿了多少，我根本不在乎他们拿了多少。我知道我妻子因为他们的所作所为度过了她一生中最美好的时光。我永远感激不尽。
We heard this from other people as well. We spoke to a woman-- she didn't want her name to be used-- whose mom had lung disease and signed forms with Caramadre multiple times. Her mom made around $20,000, according to Caramadre.
我们也从其他人那里听到了类似的话。我们采访了一位女士——她不想公开名字——她的母亲患有肺病，多次签署了卡拉马德雷的表格。据卡拉马德雷说，她妈妈赚了大约20000美元。
What he gave my mom-- at the time, she had been sickly, and financially, as most people in her age group, things like prescriptions were becoming a stretch to afford. She couldn't buy Christmas presents for her grandchildren and her great grandchildren. And there were certain things that she needed, whether it be hair color or to go to Wright's Chicken Farm with the elderly and whatnot. She didn't have her own money for that, so she relied on us for that, and that bothered her. [SOFT CRYING]
他给我妈的——当时，她一直体弱多病，在经济上，像她那个年龄段的大多数人一样，处方药之类的东西开始变得难以负担。她无法为她的孙辈和曾孙辈购买圣诞礼物。还有一些她需要的东西，无论是染发剂还是和老年人一起去怀特养鸡场（Wright's Chicken Farm）等等。她没有自己的钱做这些，所以她依靠我们，这让她很困扰。[轻声哭泣]
I'm sorry.
很抱歉。
I did good until now. But working with Joe, the compensation he gave her gave her back her dignity. She would go to the mall with my granddaughter and I, and when I said no to a Webkinz, my mom could say, I can do this. And that made her-- that's what gave my mom happiness, really.
我刚才还表现得很好。但与乔共事，他给的报酬让她找回了尊严。她会和我的孙女和我一起去商场，当我对购买Webkinz（一种玩具）说不时，我妈妈可以说，我可以买这个。这让她——这才是真正给我妈带来快乐的东西。
Throughout the mid to late 2000s, Caramadre increased the number of deals he did, as he took advantage of something people in the life insurance business now call the arms race. To an insurance company, a variable annuity seemed like a great deal. You get this big chunk of cash. It's locked up and delivers a great stream of money from fee income.
在2000年代中期到后期，卡拉马德雷增加了他交易的数量，因为他利用了人寿保险业务中现在被称为军备竞赛的东西。对保险公司来说，变额年金看起来是一笔好生意。你得到了这大笔现金。它被锁定并从费用收入中提供了一股巨大的现金流。
And so insurance companies competed with each other for the business of customers like Joe Caramadre by offering more and more enticements in their variable annuity packages.
所以保险公司通过在他们的变额年金方案中提供越来越多的诱惑，互相竞争乔·卡拉马德雷这类客户的业务。
As companies figured out in the early 2000s that this was a great profitable situation, their only goal was to accumulate assets. So they started with deposit bonuses. I give them $1 million. They put $50,000 or $60,000 right in my account, day one. So I earn 6% the day I buy this.
当公司在2000年代初发现这是一个巨大的盈利局面时，他们唯一的目标就是积累资产。所以他们开始了存款红利。我给他们一百万美元。他们第一天就在我的账户里存入50000或60000美元。所以我买下它的第一天就赚了6%。
In other words, life insurance companies literally paid people to buy these products. But wait, there's more. They also provided increasingly exotic investment options for where you could put your money.
换句话说，人寿保险公司简直是付钱让人购买这些产品。但这还没完。他们还为资金的投资方向提供了越来越具有异国情调的选择。
Double beta funds, inverse funds. You could bet the Japanese yen, the Mexican peso. You can bet the Saudi Arabian nuclear fund. I'm making a joke there, but there were funds that I never even heard of.
双倍贝塔基金、反向基金。你可以押注日元、墨西哥比索。你可以押注沙特阿拉伯核基金。我是在开玩笑，但有一些我甚至闻所未闻的基金。
And these are all riskier and riskier funds but that offered potentially greater and greater returns?
而且这些都是风险越来越大的基金，但提供了可能越来越高的回报？
Yes. And we did not pick very stable, secure funds, government bond funds, which we knew would not have much risk or much reward. I'm going to pick the most aggressive fund known to man that is available in that variable annuity portfolio.
是的。我们并没有选择非常稳定、安全的基金，比如政府债券基金，我们知道那种基金不会有太多风险或回报。我会挑选在该变额年金投资组合中为人所知的、最激进的基金。
Companies piled on more bells and whistles with fancy names, rising floors, earning enhancements, bonus credits, ratchets. For Caramadre and his team, they watched each new enticement, each new bell and whistle, each new escalation in the arms race with glee and amazement. One broker I talked to said perusing the latest prospectuses and picking the best benefits for their clients was like ordering off a Friendly's menu.
公司又增加了带有花哨名称、上升底线、收益增强、红利积分、棘轮效应等更多花样。对于卡拉马德雷和他的团队来说，他们带着幸灾乐祸和惊讶观察每一个新的诱惑，每一个新的花样，每一个军备竞赛中的升级。我交谈过的一位经纪人说，细读最新的招股说明书并为客户挑选最好的利益，就像从 Friendly's 菜单上点餐一样。
Every month or so, my firm would come out with the top 10 lucrative variable annuities. Some of these were so incomprehensible when put on a chart, I had people laughing out loud at my office.
每个月左右，我的公司都会发布十大赚钱的变额年金。其中一些放在图表上时简直令人无法理解，我办公室里的人都大声笑出来了。
And so over time, the insurance companies are taking what was essentially a sweet deal for you and making it sweeter and sweeter and sweeter.
所以随着时间的推移，保险公司把这对你来说本质上就是一笔好买卖的东西，变得越来越甜，越来越甜，越来越甜。
Yes, and much more dangerous to them.
是的，而且对他们来说也越来越危险。
I've talked with several actuaries and risk managers in life insurance companies, and they say they were aware of the risk, and they'd urge caution when new enticements were being discussed. But the eagerness to increase sales always carried the day.
我和人寿保险公司的几位精算师和风险经理谈过，他们说他们意识到了风险，在讨论新的诱惑时，他们也敦促要谨慎。但增加销售额的渴望总是占据上风。
Plus, the insurance companies thought they would hardly ever have to pay out these death benefits.
另外，保险公司认为他们几乎永远不需要支付这些死亡赔付。
And also remember, throughout much of the 2000s, the market was doing pretty well, so chances were your account would be worth more than the death benefit anyway. That all changed with the financial crisis. The initial investments had lost money, but the insurance companies were still on the hook to pay that initial investment. So those death claims started to matter to the companies a lot more. And a few noticed that they were getting more claims than mathematical models predicted they would.
而且记住，在整个2000年代大部分时间里，市场表现得相当不错，所以你的账户价值很可能无论如何都会超过死亡赔付。这一切随着金融危机发生了变化。最初的投资亏损了，但保险公司仍有义务支付那笔初始投资。所以那些死亡赔付对于公司来说开始重要得多了。而且少数人注意到他们收到的赔付申请比数学模型预测的要多。
Apparently, they had done some sort of a map of where all these claims were coming from, and there were a lot of red dots around Cranston, which is where Joe was operating out of.
显然，他们绘制了所有这些申请来源的地图，克兰斯顿周围有很多红点，而那正是乔开展业务的地方。
This is Robert Flanders, a former Rhode Island state Supreme Court Justice, now in private practice, who served as Caramadre's attorney when the insurance companies started suing him.
这是罗伯特·弗兰德斯（Robert Flanders），前罗德岛州最高法院大法官，现从事私人执业，在保险公司开始起诉卡拉马德雷时，他担任了卡拉马德雷的律师。
Flanders represents Caramadre in cases brought by two life insurance companies, both owned by the same conglomerate. The companies claimed that the applications that Caramadre filed were false and misleading, in part because they didn't tell the company that the annuitants were dying.
弗兰德斯在两家由同一企业集团拥有的人寿保险公司提起的案件中代表卡拉马德雷。这些公司声称卡拉马德雷提交的申请是虚假和误导性的，部分原因是他们没有告诉公司被保险人正在死亡。
To which Flanders argued, essentially, well, you didn't ask.
对此弗兰德斯本质上辩称，嗯，你们没问。
Who knows better than insurance companies how to vet people for health reasons when they want to do so? Try and take out a life insurance policy and try and skate by the insurance company when you've got some medical condition. The fact is, they didn't really care about it, and that's reflected in the fact that they didn't ask any of those questions. They didn't want to.
谁比保险公司更清楚当他们想做的时候，如何出于健康原因对人进行审查？试着去投保人寿保险，并在你有某种医疗状况时试图瞒过保险公司。事实上，他们并不真正在乎这一点，这反映在他们没有问任何那些问题的事实中。他们不想问。
But what happened here is Caramadre turned this into a business. And it was OK, I guess, when he was doing it for friends and family and making occasional scores along the way. But when they started plotting out all the claims and saw that this guy was actually coordinating a voluminous submission of claims, and then as they dug a little deeper and found out that he had actually placed ads in the newspaper advertising for terminally ill patients, they just, I think, finally threw up their hands and said we've got to stop this somehow, some way. We're getting taken to the cleaners here.
但这里发生的是卡拉马德雷把它变成了一门生意。当他只是为了朋友和家人这样做，并偶尔赚一笔时，我想还可以。但当他们开始规划所有这些申请并发现这个家伙实际上是在协调大量的理赔提交，然后当他们稍微深入挖掘并发现他实际上在报纸上刊登广告招募绝症病人时，我认为他们终于举手投降说我们必须以某种方式阻止它。我们在这里被剥削了。
Of course, Flanders is quick to point out they could've stopped it themselves any time they wanted to.
当然，弗兰德斯很快指出，他们随时都可以自己阻止它。
All they had to do was change their applications or preclude this in their contracts, change the forms. These are the lords of the forms, these folks. All they had to do was put something in there, ask the right questions, or preclude terminally ill patients from participating as annuitants, and it would've stopped it.
他们所要做的就是改变他们的申请或在他们的合同中排除这一点，改变表格。这些人是表格之王。他们所要做的就是在里面放点什么，问正确的问题，或者排除绝症病人参与作为被保险人，它就会停止。
To date, there have been at least eight civil court cases filed against Caramadre or his investors. So far, a federal judge in Rhode Island has largely sided with Caramadre. In one ruling, the judge wrote, quote, "It is a bit ironic for plaintiffs, the life insurance companies, to suggest that they did not know the true nature of contracts that they themselves drafted."
迄今为止，已经有至少八起针对卡拉马德雷或其投资者的民事法庭案件。到目前为止，罗德岛的一名联邦法官在很大程度上站在了卡拉马德雷这一边。在一项裁决中，法官写道，引述，“对于原告，即人寿保险公司来说，暗示他们不知道自己亲自起草的合同的真实性质，这有点讽刺。”
And now from the NBC 10 I-Team, who would use terminally ill patients to line their own pockets?
现在来自NBC 10调查小组，谁会利用绝症病人来填满自己的口袋？
But Caramadre still wasn't home free, because there was a criminal case forming against him as well.
但卡拉马德雷仍然没有脱离困境，因为针对他的刑事案件也在形成。
One Road Islander has allegedly been arranging annuity investments using patients who are near death. NBC 10's chief I-Team reporter--
一位罗德岛人据称一直在利用处于死亡边缘的病人安排年金投资。NBC 10的首席调查小组记者——
Alex Blumberg and Jake Bernstein.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格和杰克·伯恩斯坦。
Coming up, second thoughts about multi-multi-multimillionaires. Profiting from the deaths of strangers. Alex and Jake continue the story in the second half of our show. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，关于亿万富翁们的想法。从陌生人的死亡中获利。亚历克斯和杰克在我们节目的下半部分继续讲述这个故事。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Loopholes, the story of Joseph Caramadre continues. He believed that the loophole that he has found in a common kind of insurance contract was perfectly legal. Not everyone agreed. Alex Blumberg and Jake Bernstein pick up the story.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天的节目，《漏洞》，约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷的故事继续。他认为他在一种常见保险合同中发现的漏洞是完全合法的。并非每个人都同意。亚历克斯·布隆伯格和杰克·伯恩斯坦接着讲述这个故事。
In June 2009, Caramadre got word that a hospice nurse he'd worked with had been contacted by the FBI and that the Department of Justice was investigating Caramadre for possible crimes. And soon enough, news of this investigation leaked to the media.
2009年6月，卡拉马德雷得知他共事过的一名临终关怀护士已被联邦调查局联系，司法部正在调查卡拉马德雷是否存在犯罪行为。很快，这一调查的消息泄露给了媒体。
This man is Joseph Caramadre, well known in business circles. He's been described as a generous and well-respected Rhode Islander, who's raised millions for the Catholic church, donates thousands to area charities. But the I-Team has learned he's also the target of a federal grand jury criminal investigation.
这个人是约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷，在商业圈内很出名。他被描述为一位慷慨且备受尊敬的罗德岛人，为天主教会筹集了数百万美元，向地区慈善机构捐赠了数千美元。但调查小组获悉，他也是联邦大陪审团刑事调查的目标。
Soon after learning of the investigation, Caramadre and his lawyer, Robert Flanders, requested a meeting with the prosecutors.
得知调查消息后不久，卡拉马德雷和他的律师罗伯特·弗兰德斯要求与检察官会面。
We met with US Attorney's Office early on and tried to persuade them that this was a civil matter at best and not something they should be having any interest in. But they were morally outraged, the lawyers were for the government, that Caramadre, in their opinion, had taken advantage of poor, old, sick people.
我们很早就与美国检察官办公室会面，试图说服他们这充其量是一起民事案件，而不是他们应该感兴趣的事情。但他们感到道德上的愤怒，政府的律师认为，卡拉马德雷利用了贫穷、年老、生病的人。
That he was a guy who was just throwing a few shekels at some poor, sick people at the end of their lives, and he was reaping the lion's share of it. And they didn't like the stink or the smell of it, and they didn't like what they considered the inequity of it.
认为他只是在一些穷人、病人生命结束时扔给他们几个小钱，而他却拿走了绝大部分收益。他们不喜欢那种恶臭或气味，也不喜欢他们认为的不平等。
Over a period of two years, a grand jury investigated Caramadre's scheme, and the FBI fanned out and interviewed witnesses. Hospice workers, investors, family members of annuitants, like Stephanie Porter.
在两年的时间里，大陪审团调查了卡拉马德雷的计划，联邦调查局四处奔走并采访了证人。临终关怀工作者、投资者、被保险人的家庭成员，比如斯蒂芬妮·波特（Stephanie Porter）。
I came home one day and found a card in the door from the FBI that said call me. And my husband came home that day from work, and I looked at him. I was laughing, and I said the FBI was here. He was like, what? I said, OK, what did you do? He goes, well, I was going to ask you the same thing.
有一天我回到家，发现门上有联邦调查局留下的卡片，说给我打电话。那天我丈夫下班回家，我看着他。我笑着说联邦调查局来过了。他就像，什么？我说，好，你做了什么？他说，好吧，我也正想问你同样的事。
Stephanie Porter's mom, Bertha Howard, had received the same visit from Raymour Radhakrishnan that Charlie Buckman and his wife had gotten. Radhakrishnan had shown up with a check for $2,000, and they'd agreed he'd come back later with papers to sign and more money. But by the time Radhakrishnan made it back for a second visit with the documents ready to go, Stephanie's mom was close to death.
斯蒂芬妮·波特的母亲伯莎·霍华德（Bertha Howard）收到了与查理·巴克曼和他的妻子相同的雷穆尔·拉达克里希南的访问。拉达克里希南带着一张2000美元的支票出现，他们同意他以后会带着要签署的文件和更多的钱回来。但当拉达克里希南第二次带着准备好的文件回来时，斯蒂芬妮的妈妈已经快要死了。
If she tried to sign her name, she'd sign instead of signing Bertha, she'd sign B-B-B-B-, then E-R-T-H-A. She tried to sign Bertha D, and it was Bertha D-D-D-D-D. So he said, you know, just do it to the best of your ability. And he said, I'm going to take the paperwork with me. We'll see what happens, and I'll be in touch.
如果她试图签名，她不是签Bertha，她会签B-B-B-B-，然后是E-R-T-H-A。她试图签Bertha D，结果是Bertha D-D-D-D-D。所以他说，你知道，尽你最大的努力签就好。他说，我会把文书带走。我们会看看会发生什么，我会和你联系。
And then it just so happened that the next time he called me, he said, I just called to let you know that the company wouldn't accept your mom's papers because of all the inconsistencies in her writing. And I said, I fully understand. It was too far advanced by then. I said, but at the same time, I said, my mom passed away. And I think she had been gone a few days.
后来碰巧他下次给我打电话时，他说，我打电话只是想告诉你，公司因为你妈妈笔迹中的所有不一致之处，不会接受她的文件。我说，我完全理解。那时候已经太晚了。我说，但同时，我说，我妈妈去世了。我想她已经走了几天了。
And it was, I'm very, very sorry. What could I say but don't be sorry. I can't thank you enough for what you did for my mom and did for us. And that was the end of story, never heard from him again.
他说，我非常非常抱歉。我能说什么，只能说别道歉。我怎么感谢你为你所做的事和你为我们所做的事都不为过。那是故事的结尾，从此再也没有他的消息。
The government says this wasn't the end of the story, though. According to the government's case against Caramadre and Radhakrishnan, someone forged clean versions of Bertha Howard's signature and used them to open an account.
政府说这并不是故事的结尾。根据政府对卡拉马德雷和拉达克里希南的指控，有人伪造了干净版本的伯莎·霍华德的签名，并用它们开设了一个账户。
And it wasn't just Stephanie's mom. In November 2011, a Rhode Island grand jury issued a 66-count indictment against Caramadre and Radhakrishnan. Five of those counts involve forged signatures of dying people.
而且不仅仅是斯蒂芬妮的妈妈。2011年11月，罗德岛大陪审团对卡拉马德雷和拉达克里希南发布了66项起诉书。其中五项涉及伪造垂死者的签名。
Caramadre denies the government's allegations. He says in four out of five of those cases, what the government alleges to be forgeries were, in fact, real signatures. In the case of Stephanie Porter's mom, he says, her application was used to open an account by mistake, but no money was ever invested in that account. Documents show this to be the case.
卡拉马德雷否认了政府的指控。他说在这五起案件中的四起里，政府指控为伪造的签名实际上是真实的签名。在斯蒂芬妮·波特母亲的案例中，他说，她的申请被错误地用于开设一个账户，但该账户中从未投入任何资金。文件证明了这一点。
But the government makes other allegations as well. They charge in the indictment that Radhakrishnan, at Caramadre's behest, misled people about the true purpose of the documents they were signing in order to get their signatures and personal information.
但政府还提出了其他指控。他们在起诉书中指控，拉达克里希南在卡拉马德雷的授意下，误导了人们关于他们正在签署的文件的真实目的，以便获取他们的签名和个人信息。
The indictment lays out 25 cases where the government alleges that this happened. According to the government, Radhakrishnan told some dying people their signatures were simply to acknowledge receipt of a charitable donation. Others he allegedly told that their family members would be the beneficiaries.
起诉书列出了25个政府指控发生这种情况的案例。据政府称，拉达克里希南告诉一些垂死的人，他们的签名只是为了确认收到了一笔慈善捐款。他据称告诉其他人，他们的家庭成员将是受益人。
The government also alleges that Radhakrishnan simply wasn't upfront about the purpose of these signatures and that sometimes the dying people had no idea someone else stood to profit. The government says this amounts to a criminal conspiracy on the part of Caramadre and Radhakrishnan to defraud insurance and bond companies and steal the identities of dying people.
政府还指控拉达克里希南根本没有如实说明这些签名的目的，有时那些垂死的人根本不知道还有其他人要获利。政府表示，这构成了卡拉马德雷和拉达克里希南欺诈保险和债券公司以及窃取垂死者身份的刑事阴谋。
The lead government prosecutor declined to talk to us, as did Raymour Radhakrishnan. Caramadre says the government misunderstood his scheme. He says he instructed Raymour to explain the program fully to all the participants and to make sure that they had an understanding of what they were signing.
政府首席检察官拒绝与我们交谈，雷穆尔·拉达克里希南也一样。卡拉马德雷说政府误解了他的计划。他说他指示雷穆尔向所有参与者充分解释该计划，并确保他们了解自己正在签署的内容。
How were the annuitants victimized, Caramadre asked? They were all financially better off after having gotten involved. He says that during the entire decade and a half he was paying dying people to fill out documents for his scheme, not one of them, or their family members, ever complained to anyone about what he was doing. None of them had a bad word to say about him. That is, until the FBI showed up and started alleging that he had committed crimes.
被保险人是如何被侵害的？卡拉马德雷反问。在参与之后，他们的经济状况都变好了。他说，在他支付给垂死者填写他计划的文件的那十年半里，没有一个人，或者他们的家庭成员，曾经向任何人投诉过他在做的事情。他们没有一个人说他坏话。也就是说，直到联邦调查局出现并开始指控他犯了罪。
Good morning Mr. Mizzoni.
早上好，米佐尼（Mizzoni）先生。
Good morning.
早上好。
My name, again, is Lee Wilker. I'm with the United States Attorney's office for the District of Rhode Island. You understand what's happening today here?
我再说一遍，我的名字是李·威尔克（Lee Wilker）。我是罗德岛区美国检察官办公室的。你明白今天在这里发生了什么吗？
I'm going to try.
我会尽量去明白。
OK.
好的。
This is sound from the taped testimony of another annuitant, Robert Mizzoni, who at the time was a month shy of his 86th birthday. Mr. Mizzoni has since died. Unlike many of the people Caramadre signed up over the years, Mizzoni had been a close friend of the family.
这是另一位被保险人罗伯特·米佐尼的录音证词，当时他离86岁生日还有一个多月。米佐尼先生后来去世了。与卡拉马德雷多年来招募的许多人不同，米佐尼是他们家的密友。
So how long have you known Joseph Caramadre?
那你认识约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷多久了？
When they were little kids, they'd come, and I used to take them in the school bus.
他们还是小孩子的时候，他们会过来，我以前经常接送他们坐校车。
So you would take Mr. Caramadre and four of his siblings in the school bus?
所以你经常接送卡拉马德雷先生和他的四个兄弟姐妹坐校车去学校？
Yeah. I had a school bus taking them to school at the Catholic school.
是的。我当时有一辆校车，带他们去天主教学校上学。
To Caramadre, Robert Mizzoni offers a prime example of how the prosecutors and the insurance companies turned people who had no beef with him, maybe even liked him, into witnesses against him.
对卡拉马德雷来说，罗伯特·米佐尼提供了一个很好的例子，说明检察官和保险公司如何将那些对他没有怨言，甚至可能喜欢他的人变成了对他不利的证人。
Over the years as Caramadre grew up and got rich, he stayed in close contact with Mizzoni and his wife. They continued to attend the same church, and he would do favors for the Mizzonis. Mr. Mizzoni himself testifies that Caramadre would prepare their tax returns for free. He helped them buy a house.
多年来，随着卡拉马德雷长大并变得富有，他一直与米佐尼夫妇保持着密切联系。他们继续参加同一个教堂，他也会为米佐尼夫妇做点小事。米佐尼先生自己作证说，卡拉马德雷会免费为他们准备报税表。他帮助他们买了房子。
And in 2004, he gave Mr. Mizzoni a check for $2,000 and signed him up as an annuitant. Caramadre says he explained the basics of the program to Mr. Mizzoni, and in fact, Mr. Mizzoni signed an acknowledgement form. But in these videotaped interviews, Mr. Mizzoni said he had no idea what was happening.
2004年，他给了米佐尼先生一张2000美元的支票，并签下他作为被保险人。卡拉马德雷说他向米佐尼先生解释了该计划的基础知识，事实上，米佐尼先生签署了一份确认表格。但在这些视频采访中，米佐尼先生说他根本不知道发生了什么。
At some time in the spring of 2004, you met with Mr. Caramadre at his office, and he gave you $2,000, right?
2004年春天的某个时候，你在办公室见了卡拉马德雷先生，他给了你2000美元，对吗？
Yeah, he gave me $2,000. But he says, I've got something for you. He gets a check, and he gave it to me.
是的，他给了我2000美元。但他对我说，我这儿有点东西给你。他拿出一张支票，给了我。
Did you have a conversation with him before that?
那之前你和他谈过话吗？
No conversation. It was just, see you later. That's the conversation.
没有谈话。就是说，回见。这就是对话内容。
You don't remember him telling you about what the check was for?
你不记得他告诉你那张支票是做什么用的吗？
No, never. Nobody told me that, nothing what it was for.
不，从来没有。没人告诉我那个，不知道它是用来做什么的。
Didn't you believe that, as a result of that meeting, you had entered into some investment with Mr. Caramadre?
难道你不相信，那次会面之后，你已经和卡拉马德雷先生进行了某种投资吗？
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
Isn't it true that you signed some documents?
你没签过什么文件吗？
I didn't sign nothing.
我什么都没签。
During this deposition, Caramadre was in the room with Robert Mizzoni, and it seemed to him like the FBI had misrepresented his scheme.
在这次证词录制期间，卡拉马德雷和罗伯特·米佐尼在同一个房间里，在他看来，联邦调查局歪曲了他的计划。
According to Caramadre, Mizzoni is telling the story this way because an FBI agent, Pamela McDade, gave Mizzoni the wrong impression when she came to interview him.
据卡拉马德雷说，米佐尼之所以这么说，是因为联邦调查局特工帕梅拉·麦克戴德（Pamela McDade）在面试他时给了他错误的印象。
Did she say why she was meeting with you?
她说为什么要和你见面吗？
You know, I think she told me about some information about Joe Caramadre. That's all.
你知道，我想她告诉了我一些关于乔·卡拉马德雷的信息。就这样。
What information did she tell you?
她告诉你什么信息？
She told me that they were checking him out.
她告诉我他们正在调查他。
For what?
为什么？
On insurance for people that died.
关于那些死亡人员的保险。
On insurance for people that died, says Mizzoni. They had a list of names, so that they could bury everybody.
关于那些死人的保险，米佐尼说。他们有一份名字名单，这样他们就可以埋葬所有人。
She had a list of names so that he could bury everybody, and he'd become a multi-multi-multimillionaire?
她有一份名字名单，这样他就能埋葬所有人，然后他就会成为亿万富翁？
She really said that to you?
她真的对你那么说吗？
Objection.
反对。
Huh?
哈？
Did she say that to you?
她对你那么说吗？
I'm just objecting to the question but--
我只是反对这个问题，但是——
I'm answering your question.
我在回答你的问题。
I know you are. Did she tell you that he would become a multi-multi-millionaire?
我知道你在回答。她有没有告诉你他会成为亿万富翁？
Yeah, he would become a multimillionaire with all the names. She showed me the names.
是的，有了这些名字，他就会成为亿万富翁。她给我看了名字。
She showed me the names, he says. But I didn't know not one of them until I seen my own.
她说她给我看了名字。但我一个都不认识，直到我看到了我自己的。
Until I seen my own.
直到我看到了我自己的。
Objection.
反对。
And what did she tell you about what these names represented?
她有没有告诉你这些名字代表什么？
Just that they represented their deaths.
只是说它们代表了他们的死亡。
The names represented death.
这些名字代表了死亡。
Did that get you upset?
那让你生气了吗？
Huh?
哈？
Did that make you upset?
那让你生气了吗？
Make me upset? Because my body is going to be sold without my wife getting a dime. How do you feel? How do you feel? How do you feel if I was to bury you, and you got insurance, and your wife don't get nothing. No way is it going to happen to me. I got news for you. They better drop this policy in a hurry. If they don't, I'll sue. How about that one?
让我生气？因为我的身体要被卖掉而我的妻子却拿不到一毛钱。你感觉如何？你感觉如何？如果我要埋葬你，你有保险，而你的妻子什么都得不到，你感觉如何？这绝不可能发生在我身上。我告诉你个消息。他们最好赶紧撤掉这个政策。如果他们不撤，我就起诉。那个怎么样？
To me, he's still a good friend, OK? Because we all make mistakes. Remember that. But this is a big one. This is a big one that comes up this way.
对我来说，他仍然是个好朋友，好吗？因为我们都会犯错。记住这一点。但这可是一个大错误。这是以这种方式出现的大错误。
If I died, he would have collected all that goddamn money, he says, when my wife wouldn't have gotten a dime.
如果我死了，他会收走所有那些该死的钱，他说，而我的妻子却拿不到一毛钱。
He would've collected all that goddamn money when my wife wouldn't have gotten a dime. Look at the beneficiary-- Paula, his wife.
他会收走所有那些该死的钱，而我的妻子却拿不到一毛钱。看看受益人——宝拉，他的妻子。
We reached out to Agent McDade, but she didn't return our phone calls. An FBI spokesman said they don't comment on active cases. To Caramadre, though, Mizzoni's anger was all about those numbers, millions of dollars that Caramadre would allegedly make off of Robert Mizzoni's death.
我们联系了麦克戴德特工，但她没有回我们的电话。一位联邦调查局发言人表示，他们不对正在进行的案件发表评论。然而对卡拉马德雷来说，米佐尼的愤怒完全是因为那些数字，即卡拉马德雷据称将从罗伯特·米佐尼的死亡中赚取的数百万美元。
He's being informed, or told, or given the understanding that my wife gets $1 million when he dies, and we only invested $10,000. So he doesn't know the real facts. I believe if he thought my wife was getting $10,000 back, and I put up the $10,000, and he already got his $2,000, he may not be upset at that at all. Of course, he would need to have been told the truth.
他被告知，或者被告知，或者理解为他死后我妻子能拿到100万美元，而我们只投资了10000美元。所以他不知道事实真相。我相信如果他认为我妻子只能拿回10000美元，而我投入了10000美元，并且他已经拿到了他的2000美元，他可能根本不会为此生气。当然，他需要被告知真相。
In November, a judge or jury will have to decide whether the scheme was a criminal one or not, and the decision in large part comes down to whether or not these dying annuitants understood what they were signing, which, when you think about it, is a complicated question.
11月，法官或陪审团将不得不决定该计划是否属于刑事犯罪，而决定在很大程度上归结为这些垂死的被保险人是否了解他们签署的内容，这仔细想想，是一个复杂的问题。
The court will have to suss out what exactly when on in those hospital and hospice rooms between Radhakrishnan and the dying people he was trying to explain Caramadre's scheme to. Remember, he was in his early '20s, just out of college, sitting across from very sick people, many on breathing machines, hopped up on pain medications, anxious family members all around. He was trying to explain how a variable annuity works.
法庭将不得不厘清那些医院和临终关怀室里，拉达克里希南和他试图解释卡拉马德雷计划的垂死者之间到底发生了什么。记住，他只有20出头，大学刚毕业，坐在非常虚弱的人对面，许多人戴着呼吸机，服用止痛药，周围是焦虑的家庭成员。他试图解释变额年金是如何运作的。
Looming over all of this are not facts, but feelings, our feelings about death. Death makes a squeamish, and people profiting from death, even more so. Caramadre says that squeamishness blinds people to what was actually going on here. According to court filings, more than 150 terminally ill people got at least $2,000 from Caramadre. Those that signed up to be measuring lives got even more. And sure, Caramadre and his clients stood to profit from people dying, but he's certainly not alone in that regard.
笼罩这一切的不是事实，而是情感，我们对死亡的情感。死亡让人忌讳，而从死亡中获利的人则更甚。卡拉马德雷说这种忌讳让人忽视了这里实际发生的事情。根据法庭文件，超过150名绝症患者从卡拉马德雷那里得到了至少2000美元。那些签署成为计量寿命的人得到的更多。诚然，卡拉马德雷和他的客户确实从人们的死亡中获利，但在这方面他绝对不是唯一一个。
A florist makes money. A church or temple makes money. A casket company makes money. A limousine company makes money. Nursing homes make money when people are sick and die. Hospitals do, OK? Pension plans make money. They can't wait for people to die so they don't have to pay them every month anymore.
花商赚钱。教堂或寺庙赚钱。棺材公司赚钱。豪华轿车公司赚钱。当人们生病和死亡时，养老院赚钱。医院也是，好吗？养老金计划赚钱。他们迫不及待地想让人死去，这样他们就不必每个月再付钱给他们了。
Our state is waiting for people to die every day so we can clear up this billion-dollar fiasco of paying pensioners. So death is involved in many aspects of our lives. So is it squeamish? Yes. But not if it's done morally, ethically, and legally.
我们的州每天都在等待人们死去，这样我们就可以清理掉这十亿美元的养老金支付惨败。所以死亡涉及我们生活的许多方面。那么它忌讳吗？是的。但如果是道德上、伦理上和合法地完成的，那就不是。
The legal part will be up to the court to decide. But the moral and ethical parts is where it gets blurry. On the one hand, Joseph Caramadre says before he even began signing up dying people, he vetted the idea with this priest. And in fact, his priest went on to become an annuity investor. The mother of the local monsignor, she served as a measuring life.
法律部分将由法庭决定。但道德和伦理部分是模糊的地方。一方面，约瑟夫·卡拉马德雷说在他开始招募垂死者之前，他曾向牧师咨询过这个想法。事实上，他的牧师后来成为了一名年金投资者。当地蒙席（monsignor）的母亲，她担任了计量寿命。
On the other hand, there are people like Stephanie Porter, the woman whose mother was too weak to sign the documents. Even though she and her mom were willing to sign on with Caramadre, as she's learned more, she's horrified.
另一方面，像斯蒂芬妮·波特这样的人，她的母亲虚弱到无法签署文件。尽管她和她妈妈愿意和卡拉马德雷签约，但随着她了解得更多，她感到恐惧。
You're using people. You know that they're going to die, and you're using them to your advantage so that you can gain? It just disgusts me to think of it that way.
你在利用人。你知道他们会死，而你为了获利利用他们？想到这一点我就感到恶心。
When you talk to Caramadre, the way he explains it is, I can get this advantage from the insurance company for myself and my clients. I can pay somebody who is at the end of life a little bit of money for their signature, and everybody is happy. Does that reasoning make any sense to you?
当你和卡拉马德雷交谈时，他的解释是，我可以为自己和我的客户从保险公司获得这种优势。我可以付给一个生命尽头的人一点钱作为他们的签名，每个人都开心。这种推理对你有什么意义吗？
No. So you put a dollar amount on my mother's death is basically what it comes down to. I lose my mom, who's my best friend, who's my world, and in me losing my mother forever at the age of 64, you in turn profit and get x amount of dollars. It's slimy what the man did.
没有。所以你基本上是给我妈妈的死亡定了一个金额。我失去了我妈妈，她是我的好朋友，是我的全世界，而在我失去我64岁的母亲永远地离开我时，你反过来获利并得到了X数量的美元。这个男人所做的一切是卑鄙的。
No matter what the court decides, Caramadre's scheme would not be possible today. Several of the companies Caramadre targeted have stopped selling these variable annuities. Not because of what Caramadre did, but because the promises they made are proving too expensive to deliver. Death turned out to be a bad business for them.
无论法庭决定什么，卡拉马德雷的计划在今天都是不可能实现的。卡拉马德雷瞄准的几家公司已经停止销售这些变额年金。不是因为卡拉马德雷做了什么，而是因为他们做出的承诺被证明成本太高，无法兑现。死亡被证明对他们来说是一门糟糕的生意。
They are potentially on the hook for a huge amount of money. Some companies have already declared billions in losses. Almost all of them have changed their contracts. Caramadre's loophole has been closed.
他们潜在地背负着巨额资金赔付责任。一些公司已经宣布了数十亿美元的损失。几乎所有公司都修改了他们的合同。卡拉马德雷的漏洞已经被堵上了。
Jake Bernstein and Alex Blumberg. Alex is one of the producers of our show. Jake is a reporter with the nonprofit investigative news organization ProPublica. A more detailed version of their story with video excerpts of the depositions you heard and graphics and documents is at ProPublica's website.
杰克·伯恩斯坦和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。亚历克斯是我们节目的制片人之一。杰克是非营利调查新闻机构ProPublica的记者。他们故事的更详细版本，包含你听到的证词视频片段、图表和文件，可以在ProPublica的网站上找到。
They're also interested in having a real discussion with people about whether it is acceptable to profit from the deaths of strangers, and I hope you might join that. You can do that at propublica.org.
他们也有兴趣与人们进行真正的讨论，探讨从陌生人的死亡中获利是否可以接受，我希望你也能加入。你可以在 propublica.org 上这样做。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our office manager. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼希（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、阿莉莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同完成。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格德斯（Rob Geddes）。
Production help from Tarek Fouda. Special thanks today to Joe Rosenberg for telling us about Kathy Stuart's research on 17th century suicides by proxy, and for helping us produce that story. And thanks to Michelle Harris. Kathy Stuart's book Suicide by Proxy, crime, sin and salvation, and enlightment in Germany, will be out in 2013.
制作协助来自塔雷克·福达（Tarek Fouda）。特别感谢乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）告诉我们关于凯西·斯图尔特关于17世纪代理自杀的研究，并帮助我们制作那个故事。感谢米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。凯西·斯图尔特的新书《代理自杀：德国的犯罪、罪恶、救赎与启蒙》将于2013年出版。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He keeps sending out these hilarious-- You're fired. Just kidding!-- greeting cards to the WBEZ staff.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他总是寄出这些搞笑的——你被解雇了。开玩笑的！——贺卡给WBEZ员工。
The expression on the poor manager's face was such that the poor guy said I'm going to lose my job.
那位可怜经理脸上的表情是这样的，那个可怜的家伙说我会被解雇的。
I'm Ira Glass back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。